nice so this is Robert McCall you know
this is beautiful I really love it we
got some like governance here we got a
little bit of like some Soviet that
looks like some Soviet European action
here some humans bunch of humans diverse
humans still some animals we had some
people looking like they're flying over
here which is great we have this like
massive like spaceship structure or
futuristic and stuff water fountain we
still have a star in the cosmos and
planets and your body looks like some
space stations and some like P looks
like we're using nuclear fusion to power
some of this stuff yeah and I think Ike
would I think it brings home like the
reason for me to start the index which
was like the personal reason of course
was I wanted to kind of do to the
existential risk kind of like feeling
that I had which in my research of an AI
safety researcher but I also do like
computer like cybersecurity risk
research right now and I wanted to do to
this kind of like sober attitude because
in in in the everyday life and if you
look at those risks you almost seem to
like that I just doubt whether we even
make it through the century right like
not just AI risk but that's not a risk
and then make sure and and then now news
being nuclear weapons being back on the
table again which we thought we'd
eradicated in propaganda so we think you
know it it's it's kind of like hey are
you using the Turing Turing test well
yeah it's just this more like pessimists
and pessimists kind of like attitude
that you get to it but also I think
generally risk research is more like
this neutral kind of like very rational
assessment of risk and that's what you
know what is really important to do and
it's important that it's unbiased right
it's very important but on the other
hand it's almost makes you forget why
you even care and I think it's kind of
like how to say it and it settles the
horse from the wrong way what's the the
English term for this and that's funny
saddles the horse from the put its foot
and put the cart before the horse that's
the image way of saying it the German
ways is a different one and so it kind
of like worse it kind of like in
focusing so much on the risks
we forget why we're even doing this and
I think why we're doing this is a really
motivational component because if we
make it through this bottleneck we're in
this real bottleneck right now where we
can either really meet into order really
good feature or we could really get
extinct and we're at this bottleneck
right now which I think in an
unprivileged and ways before so I think
it's really important to remind
ourselves why we absolutely have to get
this right
to it rather than just focusing on oh
well and you know survival would be a
success that focusing in like if we get
this right it's not only survival that
we get but if we get this right the
futures not going to look just plain but
it could be really so much better so so
the why is to survive and have a great
future yeah I mean like I think survival
is already if we survive it's very
unlikely I think that we will have a
terrible future because correct given
yeah but but it's also likely that if we
survive that we do have a terrible
future because there's a class-based
speciation that will occur it's actually
quite likely to occur the amount of
wealth that's accumulated that the
economy grows by so much every decade
now because of information technology
and then it's captured mostly by the 1%
the growth of the economy so why would
they ever want to engage or interact
with the poor or middle class at all
Bill Gates can't even people he was
playing a game on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show where he had to guess the prices of
grocery store items and he thought that
of like he thought that a 40 pack of tow
Tostitos pizza rolls he thought that was
$20
he thought the Tide Pods you know the
big box of Tide Pods he thought that
that was $4 so what I'm getting at is
that there's already such a huge
disconnect between the ultra rich and
the poor in middle class that there's we
can't just say that if we make it
through the bottleneck everything will
be great because the likelihood
we first make it through the bottleneck
that's crucial to survive in the second
stages if we survive or is everybody
going to flourish like we have in this
beautiful example by Robert or is there
gonna be some king up in this castle up
here at the top of the utopic structure
that is a benevolent dictator or could
they be a group of 20 people that are
trying to progress everybody forward or
is it going to be like none of these
peasants on the hills can have the
option of entering the castle okay so I
think talking about that that we get us
again I think into a rabbit hole but I
think it's important to not forget how
much progress we've made and I think at
the event where you were on Sunday and
we hosted an event logs about artificial
general intelligence as corporations and
Mark Miller who's got this breakfast and
solid brothers you know like this
backdrop of really how much we have
progressed like in terms of absolute
poverty and and it's really those two
yes yeah and it is a graph I think that
Pinker use is great but you know and I
think it's really really really
important to not forget how far we've
come and and we understand how far we've
got okay okay yeah so I mean I I agree
that there's a lot to work to be done to
ensure that their futures are positive
rather than negative right and that
there's a lot of work that is not
technocratic and take the standard but
that has to be done on different areas
and that's why okay so maybe if we get
into the index here a little bit then it
might become more clear that what this
version actually entails yeah so I would
still like to it you know you were
saying we should we won't go down that
rabbit hole it's full but that is
something really important to discuss
it's at some point let's let's go
through the see we have time at the end
we yeah I just think that it becomes
clearer down here so for example um okay
so the reason why why I started this was
really just kind of like collecting
readings and organizations podcast
papers books people and organizations
and that work toward beneficial futures
so that two futures that give you
kind of like a hope again rather than
existential angst and terror and it's
not it really over this vision part
right I just wanted to collect like
really good readings and transhumanism
and kosm ISM and risk and threats and
extension angst and hope and and then
but also readings and big history and
big future because I think the best way
to have foresight is to really also
consider the past right and like this
historic analysis imp is important but
then it became much more than that and I
was thinking well now that we do know
kind of like what are the features that
that we could strive for one of the
different focus areas and so I made a
say I made a second section with you
know like given that if we agree on this
vision that we can create these futures
what are the focus areas that we need to
work on until we have science and tech
ions AI in cyberspace but we also have
society in economics right and this is I
think one which is really important
which you've been bringing up over and
over again and which is like the bedrock
on which everything else gets made so it
is the fundamental thing to get right
and and I'll talk about like one thing
that I'm doing for that in a second but
the third one is then given that we know
the focus areas you know here are the
tools and those are really meta tools
like lossy and rationality mine a
meditation like the toolkit that we
discussed and you know how what we given
that we know the vision and the focus
areas which are the tools that we can
apply to them and if you you know click
on any of those I mean I think the one
that we used here for at the event at
the event on Sunday was the AI section
and you know if you click on one of
those items that links you to a Google
Doc yeah and on that Google Doc I you
know come I combine like the best
readings on this on AI safety on
different items on ethics and the good
thing is that this fantastic it's a
great place for people to come and learn
yeah yeah and I and I hope not only
learn but also contribute because I'm
not an expert in all of those and
honestly not in either of those fields
because I've just started this and I
think like over 90% of this is still all
from me it's just me kind of like brain
dumping well what good readings
I find that I would really like this to
be a collaborative project so if you
find this interesting and if you are
happen to be a researcher that focuses
on any one of those fields that were on
the index then please just go on there
click on the one that you focus on maybe
you work in environment energy click on
it and then you get you know the
director to the Google Doc and you can
make comments on suggestions of
important readings in your field and I
will want every once in a while sweep
the website and put those comments on
there and and then it becomes a
collective effort to put together this
database of information have existential
hope but also of collaboration to build
that future together